[Music]
there are several questions essential
questions that leaders and managers
should ask themselves when they look at
how they want KPIs to have an impact and
influence on their organizations the
most important one is obvious what's
most important to the organization where
is value really created where is value
really created for us internally and for
our clients for our customers for our
users whether they be business or
consumers okay how do we want to measure
that what kind of performance leads to
those kinds of outcomes the big
challenge the difficult challenge the
challenge that my colleagues and I and
my clients and I and my students and I
debate and argue the most is when our
KPIs means and when our KPIs ends
sometimes we want to have key
performance because that's what
excellent means we're always greeting
customers with a smile we're always
trying to provide the easiest most
convenient the best possible user
experience there are other times when
the outcome is really what matters the
most which is we get a profit on this we
get a sale for this what our means and
ends sometimes the KPI is linked here's
how we've dramatically increased our
sales that's fantastic sales sales KPI
we've outperformed our sales KPI and
expectations Oh three weeks later three
months later the returns for what we've
sold are larger than ever before the
customer satisfaction scores or the Net
Promoter scores have dropped
precipitously
oh my gosh we have to manage trade-offs
between KPIs
the leadership challenge the management
Channel
is not just how do we do a better job of
identifying cultivating deploying KPIs
it's how do we identify and manage the
tensions and sometimes conflicts between
them again that's why this is such a fun
subject because sometimes there can be
changes where the KPIs converge or a new
KPI emerges from your observation of
means and ends many stories and
anecdotes that can be told about KPIs
that really positively and
constructively transform how an
organization behaves and they're also
sadly but obviously examples of what one
might call pathological kpi's KPIs that
make sense in the moment but when you
review their ultimate impact internally
and externally bad bad
a classic example from 10-15 years ago
back when we had call centers instead of
contact centers was time spent on calls
that many call centers were compensated
the key performance indicator was how do
we keep the call down to two minutes
three minutes five minutes
and so throughput calls per hour calls
per day were the dominant KPI because
that's what productivity was going to be
what did you end up with high throughput
very unhappy customers even oftentimes
if their situation was resolved because
the feedback was I felt rushed I felt
they were interrupting a lot it was a
bad UX it was a bad customer experience
there was also emerging at that time the
notion of first touch first call
resolution how can we get things
resolved at that time at the first one
without making the person call back or
without your calling the back
interestingly if I may digress
you know what really transformed that
KPI was chat programs because what
people could do was they could do it
chat say hey I'm having this kind of
problem what should I do with this
person and just look and they were able
to use their colleagues or a database or
a wiki to get an answer to do first call
resolution so this ties into the notion
of not just a dominant KPI but how do we
get a productive tension between KPIs
one is time spent on call the second is
effective resolution and the third is
customer satisfied you're never going to
get them all right but there's going to
be a sweet spot there and in this case
triangulating those KPIs to create a
sweet spot was transformative for a lot
of call centers that subsequently became
contact centers so remember if you pick
the wrong dominant KPI you may end up
with perverse outcomes because you are
incenting perverse behaviors if you'll
forgive me for making a bad acronymic
pun one of the ways you shock people
into this recognition is that you say
KPI doesn't just stand for key
performance indicator it stands for
key performance incentive so make sure
you're recognizing and rewarding the
right things not things that can lead to
perverse or counterproductive outcomes
[Music]